This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Hey, this is starting up. What I'm gonna have you do when you get on? I'm gonna have you just stand for a few seconds, and then when I tell you to run. That is the sound of producer Phoebe Flanagan jogging on a treadmill. She's been observed by LaGene Lawson, one of the world's leading experts on sports bras. Lawson uses all kinds of fancy equipment, like a 3D imaging machine, to understand the
这里是 99%隐形。我是罗曼·马尔斯。嘿，这个要启动了。你上来之后我让你做的是什么？我让你先站几秒钟，然后等我叫你跑的时候。这是制作人菲比·弗拉纳根在跑步机上慢跑的声音。她正在接受拉让·劳森的观察，拉让是世界上运动内衣领域的顶尖专家之一。劳森使用了各种各样的先进设备，比如 3D 成像机，来了解
biomechanics of breasts and how they move when women exercise. The breasts will rise up and then it has to go down again. It changes direction constantly, the accelerations, which is either speeding up or slowing down where the nipple is changing direction. It can be very high. I did a little research and I said, you know, a 30, 60 nipple can go from 0 to 60 faster than a Ferrari. Really? Much faster. Okay, let's see. For the past 30 years, Lawson has worked as a researcher and consultant to champion athletic wear.
乳房的生物力学以及它们在女性运动时的运动方式。乳房会向上抬起，然后又必须落下。它不断改变方向，加速度，也就是乳头改变方向时的加速或减速，可以非常大。我做了一点研究，我说，你知道，一个 30-60 码的乳头从 0 到 60 的加速可以比法拉利还快。真的吗？快得多。好的，我们来看看。在过去的 30 年里，劳森一直担任研究员和顾问，致力于推广运动服装。
She specializes in sports broad design. Sports bras are a piece of clothing that women might take for granted today, but they were totally revolutionary when they were first invented. They opened up whole new realms of sports and exercised women. Not just because I've spent 33 years studying it,
她专门从事运动内衣设计。运动内衣是现代女性可能会视为理所当然的一件衣服，但当它们刚被发明出来时，却是完全具有革命性的。它们为女性打开了全新的运动和锻炼领域。这不仅仅是因为我花了 33 年时间研究它，
do I say this? I know from conversations with literally thousands of women that this is a game changer for that. Today we're going to feature a story from our friends at the outside podcast from Outside Magazine and PRX. They did a whole episode dedicated to the design and history of the sports bra. We'll start back in Lawson's lab with reporter Florence Williams. Beyond the lab, the jeans also got a sports bra museum. Okay, here. It's filled with decades worth of vintage models. Some are more mystifying than others.
我才这么说。我从与数千名女性的交谈中得知，这对她们来说是一个彻底的改变。今天我们将推出一档来自《Outside》杂志和 PRX 的 Outside 播客朋友们的故事。他们制作了一整集专门介绍运动内衣的设计和历史的节目。我们将从劳森的实验室开始，与记者弗洛伦斯·威廉姆斯一起探索。除了实验室，拉让还有一个运动内衣博物馆。好了，就是这里。这里摆满了历时几十年的复古款式。有些款式比其他的更让人大跌眼镜。
There are so many straps. This could not be any weirder. This is called the Damon jogger, which I call the Damon jogger. And there were instructions on how to get this on, which I don't know if I can do this. You put your legs through it. Yeah, you put your legs through it. And you pull it up. Looking at all the options around the room, it's crazy to think that the modern sports broad didn't even exist when LaGene was growing up. Actually, when I started high school, we weren't allowed to run full court
有这么多的肩带。这绝对是古怪透顶了。这叫做达蒙慢跑者，我叫它达蒙慢跑者。这里还有关于怎么穿它的说明，我不知道我能不能做到。你把腿伸进去。对，你把腿伸进去。然后把它拉上来。看着房间里的各种选择，很难想象当拉让长大时，现代运动内衣甚至还不存在。事实上，当我上高中时，我们是不被允许打全场篮球的
because it was the assumption that girls were too weak. And we couldn't run any races longer than like 400 meters. So, women participating in sports and having needing a sports bra is so recent. Recent and surprisingly controversial. When Lijin started doing her research back in the 80s, she actually got some serious pushback, like this one letter that turned up at her office. This letter said, if God had intended women to run, he would not have put breasts on them. So it's sort of like, there was a whole sociocultural
因为当时人们认为女孩太弱了。而且我们不能跑任何长于 400 米左右的比赛。所以，女性参与运动并需要运动内衣是一件非常近期的事。近期且令人惊讶地充满争议。当拉让在 80 年代开始她的研究时，她实际上遭到了一些强烈的反对，比如这封出现在她办公室的信。这信上说，如果上帝希望女性跑步，他就不会在她们身上长出乳房。所以这就好比，有一种关于女性应该如何行事的社会文化
stereotype of how women should behave, and it wasn't vigorously and badly. It was, it was to be more calm and sweet and have a comport yourself with more steadiness and not the sort of enthusiasm and passion that we see with sport. To understand how the sports brought changed all that, we need to go back to 1977. It was the same year that James Fix published his blockbuster bestseller, The Complete Book of Running.
刻板印象，而那绝不是充满活力和激烈地运动。而是要更冷静、甜美，举止更加稳重，而不是我们在体育运动中所看到的那种热情和激情。为了了解运动内衣是如何改变这一切的，我们需要回到 1977 年。那是詹姆斯·菲克斯出版他的超级畅销书《跑步全书》的同一年。
And it was just a few years out from Title IX. Women were finally wanting in on the sports action after being told for generations and generations that their bodies just weren't built for sports. I started walking. And gradually as I got in shape, I began to run. Now I run three days a week. My family and friends say how healthy I look. You know, my whole generation started
那也是《教育修正案第九条》通过后不久。在被一代又一代人告知她们的身体根本不适合运动之后，女性终于想要加入体育运动的行列了。我开始散步。随着我逐渐恢复体形，我开始跑步。现在我一周跑三天。我的家人和朋友都说我看起来多么健康。你知道，我的整个代际都开始
Exercising. This is Lisa Lindahl. She got caught up in the craze and I had a friend who introduced me to What was then called jogging? And was it a new term? It was. I have to say. I went out and started jogging up at the University of Vermont indoor track. And just to get around that track once was painful. And I remember the day that I got around that track four
锻炼。这是莉萨·林达尔。她赶上了这股热潮，我有一个朋友向我介绍了当时被称为慢跑的运动？那是个新词吗？是的。我得说。我走出去，开始在佛蒙特大学的室内跑道上慢跑。只要能绕着那跑道走一圈都是痛苦的。我记得我绕着那跑道跑了四
times and completed a mile. And you would think I had one in Olympic medal. I was so proud of myself. Lisa broke a mile. Then two, then three. She started running outside. But the more she ran, the more she realized she had a new problem. Actually, two problems. her 36-sees.
圈并完成了一英里那天。你会以为我赢得了奥运会金牌。我为自己感到骄傲。莉萨跑完了一英里。然后是两英里，三英里。她开始去户外跑步。但她跑得越多，就越意识到自己遇到了一个新问题。其实是两个问题。她那 36C 的胸部。
When you have a t-shirt over bouncing nipples, you get chafing. So the answer to that is to put a bra on. And because I did try running without any bra on, and then of course I got a lot of comments from passing motorists and certain male runners. Things haven't changed much over the years. Unfortunately not.
当你穿着 T 恤，胸部却在上下晃动时，就会产生摩擦。所以解决方法就是穿一件胸罩。因为我确实尝试过不穿任何胸罩跑步，然后我当然从路过的司机和某些男性跑步者那里得到了很多评论。这些年来情况没有太大变化。不幸的是，并没有。
So you wear a bra of some sort and then that poses new and different problems like the straps that slip off your shoulders, so you're always jigging them back up, hardware that can dig into your back, and they're hot and sweaty. Lisa's sister started running, too, and one day she called her up. And she said, what do you do about your boobs, actually, is what she said. I am so uncomfortable when I'm running.
所以你穿某种胸罩，然后这又带来了新的和不同的问题，比如从肩膀上滑落的肩带，所以你总得把它们往上提，会扎进你背部的金属扣，而且它们又热又出汗。莉萨的妹妹也开始跑步了，有一天她打电话给她。她说，你对你的胸部怎么办，实际上她是这么说的。我跑步的时候太难受了。
What she said when I was talking about the fact that I had no great solution was, why isn't there a jock strap for women? That's when we really laughed. We thought that was hilarious. Lisa couldn't let the idea drop. She started working the problem. What would that bra have to look like?
当我谈到我没有好的解决方案时，她说的却是，为什么没有给女性用的护阴罩？那时候我们真的笑了。我们觉得这太搞笑了。莉萨对这个想法念念不忘。她开始着手解决这个问题。那件胸罩应该长什么样？
What would it have to do? And I sat down at my dining room table and wrote out a list that was, all right, the straps shouldn't fall off. They should be wide enough that they don't dig in. Ideally, I was hoping that it could be modest enough that I could take off my t-shirt on really hot summer days because I had a running partner who would do
它该怎么做？我坐在饭桌前写下一份清单，好吧，肩带不应该掉下来。它们的宽度应该足够宽，不会勒进去。理想情况下，我希望它能足够谦逊，以至于在非常炎热的夏天我可以脱掉 T 恤，因为我有一个跑步搭档会那样做。
that. He would take off in the middle of the run his t-shirt over his head and tuck it in the back of his shorts and I was so jealous. Yeah because I couldn't do that. But I didn't hold that a lot of hope for that in the beginning. And then somehow your husband became involved, your husband at the time. Yeah. Also had a role here. He did, because what happened is,
他会在跑步中途把 T 恤从头上脱下来，塞进短裤后面，我当时嫉妒极了。对，因为我做不到这一点。但我一开始对这个并没有抱太大希望。然后不知怎么的，你丈夫参与进来了，你当时的丈夫。是的。在这里也发挥了作用。他确实发挥了作用，因为发生的事情是，
I mean, part of the irony of this story, Florence, is that I don't so. But living with me at the time was my good friend, Polly, who had become a costume designer, and so boy did she so. And I went to her and said, Polly, help me make this. And so we started making prototypes and having difficulty because really, bras are an engineering proposition. Yeah, things need to be cantilevered. Yes, it's like building a bridge. Right, but we didn't know that at the time.
我的意思是，这个故事的讽刺之处的一部分，弗洛伦斯，其实是我不怎么做。但当时和我一起住的是我的好朋友波莉，她成了一名服装设计师，所以她真的是太会做了。我去找她，说，波莉，帮我做这个吧。于是我们开始制作原型，并遇到了困难，因为说实话，胸罩是一项工程学课题。是的，有些东西需要悬臂支撑。是的，就像建造一座桥梁。没错，但我们当时并不知道这一点。
So we were sitting in the living room, Polly and I, bemoaning the latest prototype that I had gone running in and was not cutting it. And my then husband came down the stairs and he had pulled one of his jock straps on over his head and across his breast and said, Hey ladies, here's your new jock bra. And we just thought that was very, very funny and rolled on the floor. And I got up and took it off of him and tried it on because I had to get in the act and pulled it over my chest that actually had breasts. And went, oh, I went running the next day in this jockstrap contraption and knew that it was, this was the product that was going to work.
所以我和波莉坐在起居室里，哀叹着我穿着去跑步但却不合格的最新原型。然后我当时的丈夫走下楼梯，他把他的一个护阴罩套在头上，横跨在胸前，说，嘿，女士们，这是你们的新运动胸罩。我们只是觉得这非常非常有趣，笑得在地毯上打滚。我站起来把它从他身上脱下来，试穿了一下，因为我也想参与其中，把它套在我确实有乳房的胸前，然后说，哦，我第二天穿着这个护阴罩发明物去跑步，就知道这就是那个能起作用的产品。
And Polly went to New York City and found good elastic, found a new fabric that would work for the cups. And voila, we had a working prototype. How did you come up with a name jog bra? Well, there was no such term as sports bra at the time. And so we were calling it joc bra. I like that. And we heard from some people in the south that joc was not such a nice word. And we didn't want a name that offended some people. So we changed Jock to Jock, and it became Jogbra. So Lisa started shopping her new Jogbra around to different sporting goods stores.
波莉去了纽约市，找到了好的松紧带，找到了适合罩杯的新面料。瞧，我们有了一个可行的原型。你是怎么想出“Jogbra”这个名字的？嗯，当时根本没有“运动内衣”（sports bra）这个词。所以我们叫它“joc bra”。我喜欢这个。我们从南方的某些人那里听说，“joc”不是一个那么好听的词。我们不希望有一个会冒犯某些人的名字。所以我们把“Joc”改成了“Jog”，它就成了“Jogbra”。于是莉萨开始把她的新 Jogbra 推销给不同的体育用品商店。
Most of the buyers looked at her like she was crazy. After all, why would a running store sell women's underwear? I was very clear from the beginning that this was not gonna go into lingerie. It didn't look like lingerie, it was considered ugly. And so it needed to go into sporting goods so that when a woman went in to buy her shoes, she could also get this bra. And so I had to contend with men who were the buyers. Or because women's
大多数买手看着她的眼神就像她疯了一样。毕竟，为什么一家跑步店要卖女性内衣呢？我从一开始就很清楚，这不能进入内衣店。它看起来不像内衣，它被认为很丑。所以它需要进入体育用品店，这样当女性进去买鞋时，她也可以买到这款胸罩。所以我必须与身为买手的男性打交道。或者因为女性的
undergarments had never been sold outside of the context of lingerie. Correct. To put it in lingerie would be to be minimizing its importance, minimizing its functionality. It so was not about lifting and separating and making a woman more attractive according to some fashionistas' standards. It wasn't about the bullet-pro-alook. No. And it was about functionality. I mean, it smushed the breasts, I guess, it's the chest wall. Well, there was a little bit of a uniboo fishy, right? Yes, absolutely. There was a uniboo issue. And of course, now you can have a very sexy sports bra now.
内衣从来没有在内衣的语境之外销售过。没错。把它放在内衣店里就会淡化它的重要性，淡化它的功能性。它根本不是为了根据某些时尚人士的标准来聚拢、分离并让女性更有吸引力。它与防弹外观无关。不是的。它是关于功能的。我的意思是，它把胸部压扁了，我想，就是压在胸壁上。嗯，确实有点“一眼平”的问题，对吧？是的，绝对的。确实存在“一眼平”的问题。当然，现在你可以买到非常性感的运动内衣了。
Right. But back then, it was really about function. 100%. And it took off. And it was immediately successful. Our average growth rate was like 25% per year. And we just kept growing and growing and growing. By the mid to late 80s, everywhere she looked,
对。但在当时，它真的完全是为了功能。百分之百。然后它一炮而红。它立刻取得了成功。我们的平均增长率大约是每年 25%。我们一直在不断地成长、成长、成长。到了 80 年代中后期，无论她看向哪里，
Lisa was seeing runners and others wearing sports bras. But it wasn't until the 1999 women's world cup that she realized just how far her vision had traveled. Go! Go! Remember, that's when the US soccer team had just beat China with a winning goal by Brandy Chastain.
莉萨都能看到跑步者和其他人穿着运动内衣。但直到 1999 年女足世界杯，她才意识到她的愿景已经传播得有多远。射门！进球！记住，那是美国女足刚刚击败中国队的时候，布兰迪·查斯顿攻入了制胜一球。
What a day this was and it continues from the Rose Bowl and Pasadena. The United States is one. The women's world cup. I was home in Vermont, and all of a sudden my phone started ringing. I ran to the TV set, and of course they were replaying the moment, and I went, oh, my word. And that moment, let me just describe it.
这是多么伟大的一天，它从帕萨迪纳的玫瑰碗体育场延续开来。美国队赢了。女足世界杯。我在佛蒙特州的家中，突然我的电话开始响个不停。我跑到电视机前，当然他们正在重播那一刻，我说，哦，天哪。那一刻，让我来描述一下。
She made the final winning goal. She did. As soon as that goal hit the net, she ripped off her shirt and she was wearing a black jog bra. And she pumped her fists and she showed her muscles and she was swarmed by her ecstatic teammates. And it was really the jog bra that was seen around the world. Right. The jog bra that was heard around the world. Right. The jog bra that was heard around the world. Exactly.
她踢进了决胜的最后一球。她确实踢进了。就在那个球入网的瞬间，她扯下了球衣，里面穿着一件黑色的 Jogbra。她挥舞着拳头，展示着自己的肌肉，并被欣喜若狂的队友们团团围住。这真的是一件轰动全球的 Jogbra。没错。一件轰动世界的 Jogbra。没错。一件轰动世界的 Jogbra。完全正确。
And I think what she said was it was her confidence and her preparation and the long journey that came to fruition in that moment. And that is just perfect because that's exactly what I could say about my journey in my life, really, but also the jog bra. Well, in a way, that moment also really represented the culmination of your dream. That one day, women could run around with their shirts off. Exactly, exactly. And in fact, women do. I see it all the time and I chuckle to myself. You'd see women running down the running path or the greenway here and they're in their
我想她所说的是，那是她的自信、她的准备工作以及漫长的旅程在那一刻迎来了成果。这简直太完美了，因为这正是我对自己人生旅程的写照，当然也包括 Jogbra。嗯，从某种程度上说，那一刻也真正代表了你梦想的顶峰。有一天，女性可以赤裸着上衣到处跑。没错，没错。事实上，女性现在确实这么做了。我经常看到，然后自己暗自发笑。你会看到女性在跑步小径或这里的绿道上跑步，她们穿着
running shorts and their sports bra. And that's it. So the jog bras were revolutionized women's participation in sports, but they were still geared toward women with small to medium-sized chests. What about the subset of women who were the most discriminated against of all in sports? The women with really big bezongas and often plus-sized bodies. Back at the Champion Braw Lab, Lijin Lawson says the coming up with products for large breasted women was the obvious next step. But it also required some next level engineering.
跑步短裤和运动内衣。就这样。所以 Jogbra 彻底革新了女性对体育运动的参与，但它们仍然主要面向中小胸部的女性。那些在体育运动中受到最多歧视的女性群体呢？那些胸部非常大、通常身材丰满的女性。回到冠军内衣实验室，拉让·劳森表示，为大胸女性开发产品是显而易见的下一步。但这同时也需要更高水平的工程设计。
When you're running, there are ground reaction forces coming up through your body that are two to three times your body weight, and those impacts are transmitted to your breast tissue. Our skeletons are pretty bony. They react in a certain way. The breast is sort of viscoelastic and can respond even more to the impact, stretch and distort out of shape. The larger the breast, the more mass of the breast, the more impact can affect it and create very large displacements. But yeah, mass is a big factor.
当你跑步时，地面反作用力会通过你的身体向上冲击，达到你体重的两到三倍，这些冲击会传递到你的乳房组织上。我们的骨骼相当坚硬。它们会以某种方式做出反应。乳房有点像粘弹性物质，对冲击的反应更强烈，会拉伸并变形。乳房越大，质量越大，冲击对其产生的影响就越大，并会产生非常大的位移。但是，是的，质量是一个重要因素。
That was certainly proving to be true for Renelle Broughton. Oh, I would try doubling up on sports bras. She was a hairdresser in Montana, and she'd been playing volleyball and running track with triple Ds. When you start getting up in the CD, double D triple D area, you gotta have a lot more going on there to contain those. Give us a sense of how big triple D breasts are.
对于雷内尔·布劳顿来说，这显然是事实。哦，我以前会尝试叠穿运动内衣。她是蒙大拿州的一名美发师，拥有 3D 的胸围，一直在打排球和跑田径。当你开始进入 C、D、双 D、三 D 区域时，你必须有更多的支撑来收纳它们。让我们感受一下三D胸部有多大。
Do you know what they weigh, for example? Oh, not really, but a lot. Yeah. I mean, if I were looking at a triple D breast, in front of me, what would it look like? So apparently you don't have triple D's, is that what you think? I so do not know. I'm a B. You don't know how lucky you are.
你知道它们有多重吗？哦，不太清楚，但很重。是的。我的意思是，如果我面前看着一个三D的胸部，它会是什么样子？所以显然你没有三D，你是这么认为的？我真的不知道。我是个B罩杯。你不知道你有多幸运。
I tell you what, they can be very annoying because every time you want to do anything move or, you know, I remember when I was playing volleyball, you know, the ball would roll out of the court, and I'd just stand there and let somebody else go after it because I wasn't running after that thing. Rinelle was fed up, and eventually it occurred to her to just try to hack the jog bra and make it a much sturdier feat of engineering.
我告诉你，它们会非常烦人，因为每次你想做任何动作或，你知道的，我记得当我打排球时，你知道，球滚出场外，我就会站在那里让别人去追，因为我才不会去追那玩意儿呢。雷内尔受够了，最终她萌生了一个想法，那就是尝试改造 Jogbra，把它变成一项更坚固的工程。
That was in 1985. And I tell you, the first bra that I made for myself was not pretty. We just used we just used my mother's left over fabric from different things and but I really didn't care. I didn't get that's that's the thing with me is I don't I don't really care what it looks like. I just want it to work. And what were the big innovations in in your bra? What made it different from the jog bra? It was more, there's more fabric.
那是在 1985 年。我跟你说，我为自己做的第一件胸罩一点也不好看。我们只是用了，我们只是用了我妈妈留下的做其他东西剩下的布料，但我真的不在乎。我不在乎——这就是我的特点，我真的不在乎它看起来怎么样。我只想要它管用。你胸罩里的大创新是什么？是什么让它与 Jogbra 不同？它更多的是，有更多的面料。
There's less stretch in the fabric. Because if you, what I always say, if you can take a sports bra and stretch it out enough to pull it over your head, it's only gonna stretch when it gets there. And so we knew we had to do something that had a closure in it, and I wanted the closure in the front to make it easier to get on and off. So it looks like a vest, basically. So you were able to kind of distribute the weight a little bit through this design.
面料的弹性更小。因为如果你，我总是说，如果你能把一件运动内衣拉伸到足够套过你的头，它到了上面只会继续拉伸。所以我们知道我们必须做出一件有搭扣的衣服，我希望前面有搭扣，以便更容易穿脱。所以它基本上看起来像一件背心。所以你通过这种设计稍微分散了一点重量。
Exactly. Well, Renault, why do you think large breasted women had been so ignored until this point? You know, I think it's probably a couple different things. There probably wasn't as many of us out there. I think there's getting to be more of us. So you think that breasts are actually getting bigger now? Yeah, I think they are. I think people are getting bigger.
没错。嗯，雷内尔，你为什么认为大胸女性直到现在都被如此忽视？你知道，我认为这可能是由于几个不同的原因。我们这样的人可能没有那么多。我认为现在我们这样的人越来越多了。所以你认为乳房现在真的在变大吗？是的，我认为它们在变大。我认为人们的体型在变大。
Breasts are getting bigger. Feet are getting bigger, breasts are getting bigger, feet are getting bigger. I mean, if you look at an antique pair of shoes from way back when, they're tiny. I mean, really tiny. So yeah, I think people are getting bigger. Yeah. Well, I've certainly heard that anecdotally. I know it's kind of, it's not something that's really easy to quantify. I think it's not really measured in your annual doctor's visit. No. And also, I think when girls start to develop, if they develop like starting in junior high,
乳房在变大。脚在变大，乳房在变大，脚在变大。我的意思是，如果你看一下很久以前的一双古董鞋，它们太小了。我的意思是，真的很小。所以是的，我认为人们的体型在变大。是的。嗯，我确实听说过这方面的轶事。我知道这有点，这不是一件真正容易量化的事情。我想这在你每年的体检中并没有真正被测量。没有。而且我也觉得，当女孩开始发育时，如果她们从初中开始发育，
early high school, and they're playing sports, and all of a sudden they've got these boobs that are causing problems, a lot of them will more quick. What do you think behind that? I don't know. I'm not a scientist. I'm just a big booed blonde. Renelle may not be a scientist, but we did find a woman who actually studies the stuff. Hi, Michelle.
早期的中学阶段，她们在进行体育运动，突然她们有了这些引起问题的乳房，许多人会更快地放弃。你认为这背后的原因是什么？我不知道。我不是科学家。我只是一个大胸金发女郎。雷内尔可能不是科学家，但我们确实找到了一位真正研究这个课题的女性。嗨，米歇尔。
Hi, can you first say your name and briefly what you do? My name is Michelle Larsh and I'm a senior research associate in the Department of Sport and Ex-Liscience here in the University of Portsmouth. We called up Michelle because we wanted to see if her nails instincts were right. In spite of all the innovation in sports broad technology, boobs could still be causing girls to drop out of sports. This something certainly is. Yeah, this is a really big issue, I guess, worldwide, just the general participation levels in sport.
嗨，你能先说一下你的名字以及你简短的工作内容吗？我叫米歇尔·拉什，我是朴茨茅斯大学体育与运动科学系的高级研究副研究员。我们打电话给米歇尔，是想看看雷内尔的直觉是否正确。尽管运动内衣技术不断创新，但胸部仍然可能是导致女孩放弃体育运动的原因。这绝对是的。是的，这是一个非常大的问题，我想，在世界范围内，就是体育运动的总体参与水平。
And we've looked at it in school girls in the United Kingdom. And as it is about 12% of 14-year-old girls are achieving kind of exercise guidelines. We know that as a nation, we're getting moral b since having massive health implications. So we need to try and combat that and we actually found that breasts are one of the barriers of why these girls might be dropping out or not reaching exercise guidelines. Wow, so what did you find in your research?
我们对英国的女学生进行了调查。数据显示，大约只有 12% 的 14 岁女孩达到了某种运动标准。我们知道，作为一个国家，我们的体质正在变差，这产生了巨大的健康影响。所以我们需要努力与之抗争，我们实际上发现乳房是导致这些女孩可能放弃运动或未达到运动标准的障碍之一。哇，那么你在研究中发现了什么？
Yeah, so we find that kind of in relation to, the biggest reason for lack of participation in excurs, I guess, is this breast bounce. So this kind of excessive movement in breast, that girls are very self-conscious of it. After this, again, it was changing in front of each other. So in school, they weren't comfortable, in case their breasts might be exposed to their friends. This was, again, more prevalent in larger breasts or girls.
是的，我们发现，关于缺乏运动参与的最大原因，我想就是胸部晃动。也就是胸部这种过度的晃动，女孩们对此感到非常自我意识。除此之外，还有在彼此面前换衣服。所以，在学校里，她们觉得不自在，生怕朋友看到她们的胸部。这种情况在胸部较大或女孩中再次更为普遍。
This is interesting to me. I mean, it's not necessarily that it's sort of a physics problem as much as it is almost a psychological problem. Yeah, definitely. In terms of the physics, I mean, having a good sports brow, we know we'll reduce the amount of that breast move during high or low or any kind of activity. So we can easily alter the physics of breast moving, but it's the psychological effect that they probably need
这对我很有吸引力。我的意思是，这不一定是一个物理问题，而更像是一个心理问题。是的，绝对的。就物理学而言，拥有一个好的运动内衣，我们知道这会减少在进行高强度、低强度或任何活动期间乳房的晃动量。所以我们可以轻松地改变乳房运动的物理学，但这是她们可能需要的心理影响。
education on that can kind of have a bigger impact maybe. As well as I found that nearly 50% reported that they never wear a sports bra during sports. And for us, this is kind of one of the main educational aspects that we can kind of come in with. Well, if you get a good sports bra, you can reduce this bounce during sport. And we might be able to keep school girls engaged in sport. Then do you think there's an economic piece to this as well? Possibly, but I think that we see a lot of good sports bras now that are not necessarily very expensive. So I think that it's becoming more accessible for people to have sports bras in general
进行教育可能会产生更大的影响。我还发现，近 50% 的受访者表示她们在运动时从不穿运动内衣。对我们来说，这是我们可以介入的主要教育方面之一。如果你买一件好的运动内衣，你就可以减少运动时的这种晃动。我们也许能够让女学生继续参与体育运动。那么你认为这里面也有经济因素吗？有可能，但我认为我们现在看到很多好的运动内衣不一定非常昂贵。所以我认为人们总体上获得运动内衣变得更加容易了，
and well performing sports bras. Huh. And this is really sort of an under-sung area in looking at access to health. We need to get these girls in the right equipment. Yeah, definitely. Definitely gets overlooked. We also found that they actually had massive concerns about their breasts. So, 7 to 3% reported having one breast-specific concern in sports,
而且是性能良好的运动内衣。哼。这确实是一个在关注健康获取方面被低估的领域。我们需要让这些女孩穿上合适的装备。是的，绝对的。绝对被忽视了。我们还发现她们对自己的胸部有极大的担忧。所以，73% 的人报告在运动中有一个与胸部特定的担忧，
and that they were looking for education, that they'd be happy to take in breast education, but it just wasn't there in the schools, far of them. in breast education, but it just wasn't there in the school as far as them. I think it's still a taboo subject talking about breast, and we really want to make it out that this is not a taboo. There's something we should all talk about freely, and that we can kind of educate them further on. It's been 40 years now since the first Jacques Brae hit the market. Annual retail sales of the sports bra are in the billions worldwide and growing. And it's all continuing to track
并且她们正在寻找教育，她们很乐意接受胸部教育，但学校里根本没有这些，对她们来说。在胸部教育方面，但据她们所知，学校里根本没有。我认为谈论胸部仍然是一个禁忌话题，我们真的很想表明这不是一个禁忌。这是我们都应该自由讨论的事情，我们可以对她们进行进一步的教育。距离第一款 Jogbra 面市已经过去 40 年了。全球运动内衣的年零售额已达数十亿美元，并且还在增长。这一切都在持续紧跟
with the phenomenal growth of women's athletics overall. The next 40 years will likely offer better materials, smart bras that keep track of your vitals, ever cuter, sturdier, and flashier designs, and hopefully more education to make these genius contraptions of structural engineering more accessible to the girls who could use them. Because girls need to run and play and move, even if they don't want their breasts to move quite so much.
女性田径运动整体的惊人增长。接下来的 40 年可能会带来更好的材料、追踪你生命体征的智能胸衣、越来越可爱、更坚固、更炫目的设计，以及希望有更多的教育，让这些结构工程的天才发明更能惠及那些能用到它们的女孩们。因为女孩需要奔跑、玩耍和活动，即使她们不希望自己的胸部晃动得那么厉害。
So here's to the basement sewing session, the high-tech boo-blabs, the dedicated enthusiasts who made it all possible. From all of us, happy 40th anniversary. That was Florence Williams. This story was produced by Phoebe Flanagan and edited by Peter Frick Wright with music by Robbie Carver and Dennis Funk. The story originally aired on the outside podcast, a production of Outside Magazine and PRX.
所以，为地下室的缝纫时光、高科技的胸部实验室、以及使这一切成为可能的热情奉献者干杯。谨代表我们所有人，祝 40 周年快乐。刚才那是弗洛伦斯·威廉姆斯。这个故事由菲比·弗拉纳根制作，彼得·弗里克·赖特剪辑，罗比·卡弗和丹尼斯·方克配乐。该故事最初在 Outside 播客上播出，该播客是《Outside》杂志和 PRX 的联合制作。
On the 99PI staff, Delaney Hall brought this piece into us and Sean Real made the music. Our senior producer is Katie Mingle Kirk-Colstead is the digital director, Shreef Yusuf, Emmett Fitzgerald, Taren Mazza, and Avery Truffman round out the plucky ensemble along with me, Roman Mars. We are a project of 91.7K ALW in San Francisco and produced on Radio Row, in beautiful, downtown, Oakland, California. 99% of visible is part of Radio Topia from from PRX, a collective of the best, most innovative shows in all of podcasting. We are supported by the night foundation and coin carrying donors, just like you. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook.
在 99PI 团队中，德兰尼·霍尔把这个作品带给了我们，肖恩·里尔制作了音乐。我们的资深制作人是凯蒂·明格，柯克·科尔斯塔德是数字总监，谢里夫·优素福、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、塔伦·马扎和艾弗里·特鲁夫曼与我——罗曼·马尔斯一起完善了这个充满干劲的团队。我们是旧金山 91.7 KALW 的一个项目，制作于美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心无线电街。99%隐形是 PRX 旗下 Radiotopia 的一部分，这是一个汇集了所有播客中最优秀、最具创新性节目的联盟。我们得到了奈特基金会和像你一样的广大听众的赞助支持。你可以在 Facebook 上找到这个节目并参与讨论。
You can tweet at me at Roman Mars and the show at 99PI or at one Instagram Tumblr and Reddit too. But you can stop by our place any time at 99pi.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你可以在推特上 @罗曼·马尔斯，以及@99PI，也可以在 Instagram、Tumblr 和 Reddit 上找到我们。不过你随时可以访问我们的网站 99pi.org。这期节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可留下评论。